the jurgen experience for people don't
know the
the docu-series is called sasquatch and
you look at it on hulu you go oh man
it's a bigfoot documentary
nope not really no it's a lot scarier
how did this come about like how did
this project
fall into your lap well the genesis of
the project really goes back to the fall
of 1993 i was visiting a
a buddy of mine who was working on a
dope farm and he kind of it was harvest
season which is like particularly
dangerous
time of the year up there but he kind of
got me a hall pass with the guy that
owned the farm and vouched for me
for me to parachute in for about a week
and um something that didn't make it in
the show
is that uh i went up there to do like a
heroic mushroom trip with this guy
so the the the day before
uh the day that the the [ __ ] went down
okay
um we took about an eighth month
mushrooms each and went tripping around
the redwoods now that didn't make it in
the show
okay but that night as we were coming
down
we were um in the in the cabin the
a-frame cabin that belonged to the guy
that owned the farm
and these two dudes showed up late at
night
covered in mud like splattered with mud
soaked
claiming that they'd just been to a
nearby dope farm where they'd seen
three bodies that were torn up like
mutilated and these guys were freaking
out okay they were
they seemed legitimately traumatized to
me they seemed they were exuding this
like energy of like
terror and having just seen you know
mutilated bodies to the point where
i was just trying to shrink into the
couch where i was i was like really not
happy to be in that room
at that point how old were you at the
time i was 23 years old yeah
okay i was just getting going in
journalism you know
and um they you know they the owner of
the farm kind of pulled them off to the
to the side and they were having a
conversation in the kitchen
and when they were trying to keep their
voices hushed but these guys they were
so rattled
also like i didn't know the signs at the
time but now looking back i'm like
they were on crystal they were they were
tweaking right yeah
and so they were like their voices were
going up and down in volume but they
were
but they were clearly saying that they
just like seen these three bodies
and they'd seen like sasquatch
footprints at the murder scene and they
knew it wasn't a rip-off they were
saying because
you know it was all the weed had been
harvested but it was still there like
some plants have been
torn up and thrown around right but the
bud was still there
like hundreds of thousand dollars with
the weed if it was a typical patch
and you know it was
like at one point the guy was like are
you sure they're dead everything i have
with [ __ ] you [ __ ] not listening to
us they were torn to pieces man they're
[ __ ] dead
you know and a bigfoot killed these guys
so and he kind of like got him out of
the farm and like sat down was like well
that was really [ __ ] weird and we
like had a laugh
you know but obviously that story
stuck with me for the next quarter
century and it was one that i kind of i
told it around like a ghost story around
the campfire kind of thing a few times
but then a friend of mine and a guy i
collaborate with joshua faye who's the
director of the series sasquatch
he uh we were just finishing up another
project together
and he texted me out of the blue and
he'd become he'd become a fan of this uh
podcast sasquatch chronicles right and
he texted me he's like dude if we could
find some sort of true crime story
wrapped up
with a sasquatch angle like we'd really
have something this is a
sasquatch chronicles it's a i don't even
listen to it i've never listened to it
but
it's a podcast that's like it's
basically like people's
reporting their sasquatch encounters
okay
and so he sent me this text out of the
blue and i hit him right back i was like
i might have one
so he's like dude like can you can you
look into that so the next step was to
get a hold of
get a hold of buddy that i was working
on you know that was working on the farm
up there
get a hold of anybody i could find that
worked in the dope game
up in northern mendocino county was near
a town called branscomb that worked in
that area at that time
in the dope game be like did you ever
hear a story like this because but our
thinking was
you know it we can't like do a series it
was just me hearing that story in that
cabinet one night but it's the kind of
story where you think like that probably
spread beyond that one
cabin right those guys didn't seem like
the type that they were going to keep
that to themselves
okay so you know after drawing a lot of
blanks we finally like hit this one sort
of
information ecosystem sub-circle up
there if you will
where people had heard that story and
they were like yes three guys did get
killed
but there's uh you know there's there's
more to it right they were like there's
there's a story behind that and it
doesn't really involve a sasquatch
actually killing these guys
but i don't i mean i don't want to spoil
the show for anybody who hasn't seen it
it's well worth
the three uh they're like 50 minutes or
so
yeah yeah something like like like our
tv show length
yeah um it's it's very intense
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience